زعزعت صور التقطها تلسكوب جيمس ويب
النظريات العلميه حول نشاه المجرات الصور
الملتقطه كشفت مجرات حلزونيه تعود الى
مرحله مبكره جدا من تاريخ الكون منذ نحو
ثلاثه عشره مليار لكن الاكتشاف دفع علماء
الفيزياء الفلكيه الى اعاده النظر في
فرضياتهم هدف رحله جيمس ويب في الاساس هو
التحديق في عصور عتيقه من الوجود لفهم
الماده والطاقه المظلمتين لكن اكتشاف هذه
المجرات لم يكن في الحسبان مزيد في
التقرير التالي مع زميلتنا هند ابراهيم من
واشنطن
صور اربكت علماء الفضاء والفيزياء ست نقاط
حمراء في عمق الكون لكن وجودها يتناقض مع
النموذج الحالي للكون فالصور التي التقطها
تليسكوب جيمس ويب كشفت عن مجرات هائله
تعود الى عصور مبكره من عمر الوجود عصور
لا يمكن بحسب النظريات السائده ان تنمو
فيها مجرات عملاقه
ومكنت تقنيه استشعار الاشعه تحت الحمراء
تلسكوب الفضاء الشهير من رصد المجرات التي
تشكلت قرابه 500 سنه فقط بعدما يعرف
بالانفجار العظيم اي في مرحله لم يوجد
خلالها ما يكفي من الماده والوقت لتشكيل
مجرات تحتضن مئات الملايين من النجوم
حالها حال مجرتنا درب التبانه التي استغرق
نضوجها اكثر من ثلاثه عشر مليار سنه
وفق مجله نيتشر فان كلا من هذه المجرات
تزن مليارات المرات اكثر من شمسنا وهي
حمراء لان الكون يتمدد والضوء الذي يمر
عبره يتمدد ويصبح اطول موجيه واكثر
احمرارا
وقد صورت السكوب هابل في السابق مجرتين من
المجرات الست الا ان الصور لم تكن واضحه
[موسيقى]
يستبعد بعض العلماء ان تكون هذه الاجسام
السته مجرات انما هي ماده شديده السخونه
تدور حول ثقب اسود وقد تكون مؤشرا على ان
الامور تسارعت في مراحل نشوء الكون بشكل
اكبر مما كان متوقعا او ان السماء تتوسع
بشكل اكبر مما كنا نعتقد لصباح العربيه
هند ابراهيم واشنطن
قبل نحو 100 عام فقط كان يعتقد ان مجره
درب التبانه لا يتجاوز عرضها بضعه الاف من
السنوات الضوئيه كان معظم الناس يعتقدون
انها تمثل الكون باكمله في القرن السابع
عشر كان عالم الفلك الفرنسي شارل ميسي يعد
قائمه بالاجسام غير النجميه حين رصد عددا
من الاجسام الضبابيه الغامضه في السماء
ولم يعرف وقتها انها مجرات اخرى وفي
ديسمبر من عام 1924 اعلن عالم الفلك
الامريكي ان السديم الضبابي او الغازي
اندروميدا هو في الواقع مجره اخرى وان درب
التبانه ما هو الا مجره وسط العديد من
المجرات في الكون اكتشف هابل عشرات
المجرات قبل انتهاء العشرينيات من القرن
الماضي وقدم اول نظره ثاقبه لاصل الكون
اطلقت ناس اسمه على تلسكوبها الفضائي الذي
دخل الخدمه عام 19
90 اما جيمس ويب خليفه تلسكوب هابل الذي
يستكشف البدايات الاولى لنشاه الكون وبصور
عاليه الدقه حقق العديد من الانجازات
الفلكيه المذهله منذ اقلاق اطلاقه عام
2021 اهمها اول صوره ملونه للفضاء والاكثر
تفصيلا على الاطلاق لنشاه الكون
على كل اللي نفهم اكثر ينضم لنا في
استوديو البروفيسور مشهور الوردات واستاذ
الفيزياء الفلكيه بكليه علوم وتكنولوجيا
الفضاء في جامعه الشارقه يسعد صباحك اهلا
بك شكرا تواجد معنا صباح الخير يعطيكم
العافيه
هل يمكن اعتبار ما اكتشفه تلسكوب جيمس ويب
مجرات جديده
بدايه صباح الخير عليكم وعلى جميع
المشاهدين
الاكتشاف الذي تسنى لنا من خلال تلسكوب
الفضاء جيمس ويب الذي يبلغ قطر مراته ست
امتار ومطليه بالذهب طبعا لرصت الامواج
تحت الحمراء
فهذه المجرات لا يمكن رصدا الا بهذا
النطاق النطاق الامواج تحت الحمراء
هل يمكن اعتبارها مجرات نعم هنالك
احتمال قوي جدا ان تكون هذه المجرات هي ما
زالت في طور الارصاد هذه الارصاد كانت هي
بعران
تصوير مباشر في كاميرات خاصه الان ستدخل
مرحله الرصد من خلال المطياف الفلكي ان
الفلكي سيبين لنا ماهيه هذه الاجسام وما
الغازات التي تتواجد في هذه البقع
طيب بروفيسور مشهور اليوم مع اطلاق جيمس
ويب كان في امل وتعويل على ان يكون هناك
عصر جديد منال لاستكشافات اليوم مع هذه
المعطيات التي بدات تتوالى كل مره وكل
فتره عندما تصدر هذه التقنيه الصور هذه
التي نراها عن هذا الكوكب هل هذا يعيد
مثلا صياغه النظريات والاولويات لتشكيل
الكون لانه في كل مره تظهر معلومه جديده
كانها تنسف المعلومات اللي قبلها لفهم
بنيه الكون سؤال رائع
النظريه قابله للتعديل هي ليست مطلقه لا
يوجد في العلم شيء مطلق نحن الان في صدر
الاكتشافات مازلنا
وهذا يدل على انه يمكن ان تكون هذه بدايه
تغيير لنظريه البيج بانك التي هي الان هي
النظريه المسيطره ضمن النظريات الاخرى مثل
نظريه اوتار الفائقه مثل نظريه الاكوان
المتعدده لكن نظريه الانفجار الاعظم هي
النظريه الاقوى لناكل لكنها ليست مطلقه
وهذا مفتاح للتحقق من صحه تلك النظريه
ستنسف اول شيء هل عمر الكون هو 13.7 مليار
سنه ام 13 ام اكثر من اقل هذا الان وكان
موضوع قبل ذلك عليه اشاره استفهام عمر
الكون ايضا هنالك شيء اخر
ما يفصلنا عن هذه المجرات للعلم هذه
المجرات تم تصويرها بما يسمى بالجرافيتيشن
اي هي تقع خلف كلاستر من العناقيد المجريه
من العنقود المجري ضخم جدا في اكثر من 500
الف مجره وهذه المجرات تقع خلفها وتم
رصدها من خلال كيف العدسه بتعمل مثل
العدسه النظاره هاي بتكسر الضوء بنفس
الفكره فاحنا شفنا الجسم خلف هذه المجرات
هذه الاجسام او هذه المجرات الست التي تم
رصدها من قبل جيمس ويب تقع خلف مجرات ضخمه
مجرات معروفه
مئات الالاف من المجرات فيها استخدمت
كعدسه جاذبيه
لحذف او حرف هذه المسارات الضوئيه
وتصويرها لذلك القضيه ليست سهله بعد هذه
المجرات سحيق جدا هي من هي بعيده جدا يعني
انها مع بدايات نشوء الكون هل الكون نشا
فعلا قبل 13/7 من عشره مليار سنه ام قبل
ذلك ان بعد ذلك
يعني اخذ نضوج جهات 13 مليار سنه البعض
يتساءل لماذا
هذه المجرات يعني تشكلت بهذه السرعه لم
يتوقعها العلماء نعم المجره حسب النظريه
انفجار الاعظم تحتاج الى وقت طويل لتشكل
من الغازات الاولى اللي هي معظمها من
الهيدروجين ومن ثم بعض الذرات الهيليوم
فيما بعد لكن كيف تتشكل في عمر قصير مجره
هنا التقرير يقول ان 500 سنه 500 سنه
لاشين في عمر الكون هذا لا يمكن حسب
النظريه التي بين ايدينا فاذا هنالك
اكثر من موضوع تحته اشاره استفهام اول شيء
عمر الكون ثاني شيء ما يفصلنا الماده
لتفصلنا بيع عن هذه المجرات لابد من
التحقق منها ثالث شيء هل هي فعلا هذه
مجرات ام هي اجسام اخرى ربما تكون ليست
مجرات اخرى مشهور هناك من يقول وفق
المعلومات التي وردت من جيمس ويب بانه تم
اكتشاف اكثر من 4000 كوكب هل هذا يعني
باننا اقتربنا اكثر فاكثر ان نكتشف كواكب
اخرى قابله للعيش غير المريخ الذين تحدث
عنه وهل جيمس ويب اصلا مؤهل بامكانيات
نستطيع تصديقها ونمسح نظريات التي سبقتها
اولا سابدا من اخر سؤال اللي هي هل جيمس
ويب نستطيع ان نصدق ما ياتينا به نعم جيمس
ويب من افضل سكوات وهو الافضل الان اتربى
على
الفضاء خليفه لتلسكوب الذي ما نزل يعمل
الى الان طبعا لكن التلسكوب له هدف محدد
وهو رصد تحت الاحمر بالامواج تحت الحمراء
رصد الكواكب التي تفضلت في حضرتك ورصد
المجرات العميقه في عمق الكون السحقه في
عمق الكون هل هذه الكواكب الهايلانت تجاوز
عددها الان 5000 كوكب واكتشفت طبعا
باستخدام تلسكوبات اخرى ليس فقط
2021 نعم بينما عندنا الان قائمه طويله من
الكواكب بعضها الان ما ندرسه واحنا نحن
هنا ايضا في جامعه الشارقه نقوم بهذه
الدراسات ما ندرسه هل هذه الكواكب تقع ضمن
النطاق القابل للعيش مسميتها زون هل هي
فعلا هجما ودرجات الحراره واجوائها تشابه
تشبه الارض وحتى لو اشبهت الارض حتى لو
اكتشفنا ارض اخرى نتحدث عن مسافات هائله
تفصيلنا عن هذه النجوم وكواكبها اها يعني
على امل كمان يشوف لنا جيمس ويب اذا فعلا
في فضائيين عايشين طالما كثر الحديث مؤخرا
عن مركبات فضائيه وفضائيين نتحدث عن عن
كواكب ونجوم ومجرات اما نتحدث عن شيء اصغر
من ذلك فهذا اعتقد شبه مستحيل ان نرصد حتى
اجسام او حتى نبحث عن عن ادله على وجود
ولو اشارات ان هذا الكوكب يحتوي على
كائنات او خلايا حيه فقط خليه واحده تكفي
شكرا لكم يعطيكم العافيه